I'm joined today by Rachel Sherman who's
an associate professor of sociology at
the new school in New York also author
of the new book uneasy Street the
anxieties of affluence I just finished
the book Rachel very very interesting
the concept is you interview a number of
wealthy families all in New York City
how did the project start how did you
think to do this well I had it came out
of an earlier project that I had done on
luxury hotels actually where part of
that project involved interviewing
people who stayed at luxury hotels and I
felt like they were a little bit
conflicted about sort of their
entitlement or their right to stay in
those kinds of places and very concerned
about how they should behave there and
that got me thinking about their
lifestyle choices and kind of how they
felt about those choices and I also did
some research on the lifestyle
management industry also known as the
personal concierge industry in which I
found you know I was a little bit behind
the scenes on wealthy people's
consumption so I just wanted to talk to
people about you know people who had
some extra money basically had some
flexibility and how they spent money
about how they made those decisions so
you don't identify the people that you
talk to in the book but you sort of talk
about their marital situation family
situation net worth etc and sort of
described them qualitatively in that way
was it even telling people that you
weren't going to identify them
personally was it difficult to get
wealthy couples to talk to you and to
tell you about their spending and their
finances yeah I mean mostly I did not
interview couples just to clarify mostly
interviewed people individually and in
the few cases where I did interview
couples it wasn't only I think in two
cases don't leave them together but then
write my so it to be clear what you
interviewed people who were in
relationships but you would only
interview people individually is that
more fair yeah I mean it doesn't really
matter that much but yeah and I
interview I didn't review a couple of
couples together which is enlightening
in a different way and I should also
point out that I only interview parents
people who were I think they were all
married my subjects some of them are gay
and lesbian but they're all
parents and they're all coupled so yeah
I mean partly because when I went into
this project I really was thinking about
it as a kind of study of big consumption
decisions right like the kinds of you
know where you're gonna send your kid to
school where you're gonna buy a house
how you're gonna renovate your house
what you do with your leisure time so I
went in thinking about that and having
framing the project just being around
lifestyle choices and then it just
became clear over the course of the
project that it was really difficult for
people to talk about money in general
and people have different ways of
dealing with it certainly some of them
did not want to talk to me very
explicitly about it although ultimately
I think they did and you brought up the
question of confidentiality even with
that promise of anonymity and
confidentiality the it was still you
know sometimes people were not as free
as you might imagine that they would be
about specific but particularly about
their assets and and specific numbers
one of the fascinating things I found
from reading the book is the way in
which you would see sort of based on the
politics of the individuals how they
sort of differently described their
relationship to the money that they had
and sometimes it was money that was
acquired through inheritance sometimes
it's money that's acquired through their
or their significant others work in
other words sort of like earned wages I
guess we would call them and the way
that these individuals sort of related
to wealth and also to the rest of
society did seem to differ based on what
the sort of political predispositions
work and you talked a little bit about
that yeah I think it's complicated to
think about there are definitely
differences among these people and how
they relate to their wealth it's a
little bit complicated to map those with
any degree of confidence so more
progressive people were more likely to
feel a little bit more conflicted or at
least to talk to me about those
conflicts but the more progressive
people in my sample also tended to be
the people who had inherited wealth and
inherited wealth people you know in
general may be more conflicted
regardless of their politics so I think
both of those things kind of combine to
produce the more liberal guilt that
we're kind of you know familiar with
and it has to do also with their
relationship to earning money as you
said it's interesting I got an email a
few days ago from someone who had read
the New York Times piece who said why do
you use the word earn right why do we
talk about these people as earners which
sort of inherently makes it seem like
they deserve the money more and that's
something that you know why not say that
they are paid because earn has this kind
of moral meaning inherent in it which is
something that a lot of my respondents
were kind of you know trying to bring
themselves closer symbolically to
earning money even if they weren't
actually earning money so you described
the presence of this sort of liberal
guilt around wealth for more of the
progressive oriented people that you
interviewed in terms of their actions in
terms of whether it's spending on
luxuries or charitable donations if you
had the liberal guilt were you more
likely based on the people you spoke to
to maybe donate more money to charity or
to think differently about lavish
spending on luxuries yeah again it's
hard to say because a lot of the people
that I interviewed had inherited wealth
but they also had earned well so you
know they don't think of themselves they
don't talk about themselves as
inheritors the way that people who have
inherited wealth but don't also earn
significant amounts of money because
they work in academia or the arts or
nonprofits or something like that do so
it's really complicated to make these
kinds of distinctions but in the main I
think that people who the people who
gave away the most money on the
inheritor side probably across the board
the people who gave away the most money
were the people who had the most money
they're also interviewed several earners
who you know had assets of over fifty
million dollars or twenty million
dollars and they gave really pretty
substantial amounts of money to yeah but
the the progressives specifically the
kind of progressive inheritors do see
that as a really strong political
obligation and the other thing I wanted
to say about them
is that one of the things that I think
differentiates people who are more
conflicted and think about these kinds
of issues more
from those who don't is what their
social networks are like so people who
have more liberal politics and who have
more or and or who have more kind of
creative class jobs jobs where you don't
earn a lot of money tend to have more
heterogeneous social networks right they
come into contact with more different
kinds of people and they think because
of their politics I think they think
differently about people who have less
than they do they kind of amend those
people occupy a bigger place in their
imagination so that's another reason
that people in those categories were
more likely to express conflict about it
and some of these progressive inheritors
were actually better at talking about
their conflicts because many of them had
been in therapy to talk about them you
know they've been in progressive
environments where wealthy people are a
little bit more open about you they've
gone through a process which they
sometimes call coming out about having
wealth and being able to talk about it
more I've used this term before in my
program hedonic adaptation which is the
idea that as you obtain more wealth you
become accustomed to your sort of
standard of living and that becomes your
new baseline and over the long term it
doesn't really provide more happiness
than you might have had at a previous
level of wealth and I noticed in reading
some of the interviews that you did with
people the ones that you described as
upward oriented in other words they're
sort of comparing their situation to
that of even wealthier people that was
very interesting to me because
particularly when you're already wealthy
and you're comparing your wealth to that
of even wealthier people you're really
comparing yourself to an even smaller
group right I mean presumably for the
most part the more money you have it's
you're part of a smaller and smaller
percentage of the population did you
find that in in the interviews you did
you got the sense that there was like a
total beat totally being acclimatize to
this standard of living as a reasonable
and normal baseline yeah I mean I think
there's almost two different questions
there one is that yes I think across the
board whether they're you know sort of
upward oriented or down oriented people
do get used to it
and this is something a woman who might
I quote in the book talked about as
luxury creep right she's like suddenly
we spend more on a bottle of wine and we
spend more on clothes these instead of
$10 it's $20 or $30 on a bottle of wine
without even really noticing it and
that's partly because that's something
that all of their peers are doing right
and I think that there's also a process
of people in this life stage you know
people with small children mostly who
are sending them to school who are often
buying a place to live for the first
time where they're kind of consolidating
a particularly style for it so for
people who've been conflicted especially
inheritors who've been conflicted about
having money I think this is the point
where they start putting that money to
work and then they get kind of used to
it and then you know they just they're
what they're spending kind of a ratchet
up just as a function of kind of who
they're hanging out with as I said
before I think the more diverse their
networks are the more aware they are of
that process it doesn't necessarily mean
that it doesn't happen but I think they
do have some awareness of it now the
thing about upward oriented people who
are those people who who don't have such
diverse social networks typically
they're both up there upward oriented in
the sense that they're thinking of
people above them or they're thinking of
people who are like them but they're not
thinking of people who are kind of below
them and it's exactly the implication of
what you said is it is my argument which
is that as they look up they fail to
look down even though these people are
in the top two one summer than 0.1% and
so they use that looking up actually is
a way of establishing themselves as in
the middle they want to feel like
they're in the middle sort of
symbolically and they know that they're
not in the middle distributionally yeah
mine's me of the the Trump comment you
know I started with really just a small
loan of a million dollars from my dad
right exactly yeah and some of them
might recognize a little bit more than
Trump tends to you know the ways that
they've gotten ahead I had very few
people who would really strongly assert
that they had made it on their own and
even people who did do that would like
sort of on the side mentioned you know
well I had some help from my
laws or something like that they just
they kind of don't want to recognize
that but most people are even the people
who are very highly paid in jobs in
finance and someone would would talk
about being lucky or having had
particular kinds of opportunities as
well we are speaking with Professor
Rachel Sherman about her new book uneasy
Street the anxieties of affluence we'll
pause here and continue our conversation
with her we're continuing our
conversation with Rachel Sherman who is
associate professor of sociology at the
new school in New York also author of
the book uneasy Street the anxieties of
affluence rachel at the end of the first
part we were talking about sort of the
way in which the wealthy individuals you
interviewed seemed sort of adapted to
their standard of living as a new
baseline did you sort of experience that
yourself because there's a point in the
book where you write about sort of you
were adapting and sympathizing with and
having compassion for the difficulties
of managing the renovations of three
properties that someone might have
including one in the Hamptons or
whatever did you start to sort of see
the world through the types of problems
that really rich people have as well
yeah I mean I think that example comes
up particularly because the women that I
had spoken to when I started feeling
like that had relatively significant
problems with their husbands around the
control of money and I just felt very
sympathetic to the lack of recognition
that they were getting from their
husbands and then I felt like it was
distracting me from the fact that the
problems that they were talking about
how to do with the renovation of the
home in the Hamptons or whatever but the
broader issue I mean in general I I
found it very difficult to retain some
level of objectivity right we're so used
to judging wealthy people and just
thinking that there are expenditures you
know are ridiculous or are reasonable or
you know that they're nice people or bad
people or whatever it's hard to kind of
get out of that but I think as a I had
the advantage of being a relatively
experienced you know sociological
interviewer so I already know a little
bit how to how to minimize that but
being caught between the kind of common
judgments that that you know circulate
about rich people into which I'm
certainly
immune and the empathy or the
identification that interviewers often
feel with the people that they're
talking to is a little bit of a fine
line to walk yeah well in the interviews
you do ask questions that sort of try to
get at and really you have a whole
chapter about this how these wealthy
people you spoke to I don't know if it
defend is the right way but I'm gonna
use that word and then you can you can
sort of correct me or point me in a
better direction defend the wealth that
they have from a sort of deserving it
standpoint and you would see a lot of
different lines of reasoning that that
in the people you interviewed right
listen we pay lots of taxes so we're
doing what we need to do we pay the
taxes on them on the money we make and
thus it's ok or listen we still work in
other ways we take care of the kids and
do a lot of volunteering or work
wherever it is that has some kind of
social good etc talk to me a little bit
about the defenses of wealth yeah I'm
not sure I mean defenses is a reasonable
word I think justifications might be a
better word although justification kind
of has it has a connotation of
insincerity which I don't think that
these people are insincere in talking
about this I think what they're doing is
highlighting the content of the
judgments that are very broadly made of
wealthy people in American culture and
possibly elsewhere of you know you
deserve your wealth if you've worked
hard for it or you know a little bit if
you still work hard or if you you know
so if you are as you said like a
stay-at-home mother you're trying to
frame yourself as working even though
you're not working for pay or if you're
inheritor you're trying to frame
yourself as working in a job even though
you know that you didn't actually earn
the money that you're living on but the
idea of being a hard worker whether or
not that explains your money and the
idea of consuming not being an
ostentatious materialistic you know
greedy consumer and then the idea of
giving money back you know some people
refer to their taxes as you said many
people refer to their charitable
contributions or to volunteerism a lot
of people also talked about a kind of
obligation to be aware of their
privilege so even though
they sort of don't want to talk about it
they also feel like they need privately
to recognize it and they want to raise
kids who are also sort of morally worthy
good people and who themselves have all
of these traits so in those ways they
kind of draw these distinctions between
people who are entitled who are morally
worthy of welcome people who are not so
other than I mean you talked about the
more progressive people that you spoke
to tended to have more liberal guilt
about their wealth but sort of general
putting aside the broader political
identification were there specific
factors you found that made some wealthy
people more attuned to issues of wealth
inequality and the problems of the less
wealthy and the poor than others whether
it's you know they inherited money
versus they they earned it through work
or investments or whatever else what
other factors might we point to well I
think people I mean this is again some
of the opposite of the inheritor piece
but people who are actually upwardly
mobile are more you know they have
family members and friends from their
childhoods or you know communities of
origin who have much less than they do
so those people also tend to you know
keep others in their mind and the people
who have really a lot of well they're
not upwardly mobile in the traditional
sense and then many of them started
middle class or upper middle class to
begin with but then if you have 50
million dollars you're you are upwardly
mobile relative to what you started with
so they have a consciousness about that
too and I think a lot of these people
have they're not unaware that like four
people exist right they I think they all
know that one of the things I think that
happens in stereotypes of rich people is
that we imagined that rich people are
kind of incredibly stupid and shallow I
mean I mean you know these are very
well-educated people who live in the
world so they they they know that people
who have less than they do exist it's
just a partly a question of how they
manage that knowledge and some of them
take a much more aníbal approach which
says you know we're never gonna change
the system it's not my job to change the
system I'm entitled to this because I
work hard and I'm a nice person and I
you know I'm a reasonable parent so I'm
gonna give some money away and you know
I'm not going to be that conflicted
about it those people still feel the
need that I
is talking about to be morally worthy
right they still don't want to show off
their money they don't want to hoard
their money they don't want their kids
to be obnoxious or entitled right the
concept of entitlement is something that
across the board my respondents really
didn't like but the way that they sort
of see those obligations does bearing
it's interesting that you talk about you
know these are not stupid people or
ignorant people they're well-educated
I'm curious to hear your thoughts about
you know there's been a lot of different
studies about how wealth can sort of
change one's perception of reality
there's studies about the reduction of
compassion on average of wealthier
people there's this UC Berkeley study
which showed that there will be sort of
a rationalization of advantage by by
convincing oneself that they deserve it
and you explore that in the book with
this idea of hey I worked hard
etc studies that show even even sort of
mundane things like richer people are
more likely to ignore pedestrians or
there's a UCSF study about the wealthier
you are the worse you are on average at
reading the facial expressions of others
this type of thing what's your thought
after doing all the research and
interviews for your book about all of
that research that's out there yeah and
a lot of that research relies on social
psychological methods sort of
experimental methods that take place in
laboratories and I think those kinds of
methods you know sometimes just get at
something different than what I'm
looking at and I think that we have so
little research on rich people it may be
one explanation would be like there's
different kinds of rich people and some
of them you know have all of the traits
the sort of negative traits that have
been identified in these primarily
social psychological studies and some of
them have you know a stronger moral
compass of the kind that I'm identifying
or whatever but I also just think that
these are different aspects of having
the experience of having privileged so
you know talking explicitly with me
about some of these issues is gonna be
different from how people are going to
be in a lab although it doesn't matter
which people are in the lab which is
another part of this and I think what's
important is to just keep exploring
these different
and these kind of characteristics
because I don't think that they're
necessarily mutually exclusive right and
the point that I'm trying to emphasize
is not so much like rich people are
moral right but you know they're not as
evil as we think that they are my point
is more about thinking well why are we
invested in judging them as moral or not
moral no and what are the criteria that
we're using to do that so do we really
think that I'm society with the levels
of inequality that we are currently
seeing that it is okay to be you know to
have ten million dollars or 50 million
dollars or 50 billion dollars just you
know on the basis of being a nice person
or having worked hard or you know not
living in a McMansion right which and
these are the criteria that my
respondents are laying out and they are
also criteria that I think resonate with
people who who aren't rich or certainly
aren't as rich as they are do you know
how many of the people you interviewed
have read the book and is anybody upset
about how they were portrayed I don't
know and I don't know I do care and I
would be interested to know I mean again
you know I have really tried to to not
do what I think a lot of people might do
in this kind of research which is be
really voyeuristic or you know kind of
talked a lot about their homes or the
spending that they do have and and make
nice you know make the judgment myself
that they are or are not reasonable
consumers right that for example that's
a totally relative to category and I
just want to take myself out of making
those judgments I think that's not them
appreciate that I'm trying to understand
and represent their perspective but on
the other hand I have ended up talking
about things that I think are hard for
many of them to talk about and yeah you
know that might be something that they
don't like I have gone very far out of
my way to preserve their anonymity so I
hope that that makes a difference too
we've been speaking about the book
uneasy Street the anxieties of affluence
we've been speaking with the book's
author professor Rachel Sherman thanks
so much for talking to me about it I
found the book super interesting
great thank you thanks for having me